all right an extraordinarily explosive
story yesterday the details of which we
don't still fully understand donald
trump came out yesterday and claimed
that his passports had been seized by
the fbi as they served the search
warrant at his mar-a-lago home last week
now if that is true it indicates that
the fbi presumably sees donald trump as
a flight risk
and is worried about him leaving the
country and thus they have removed his
means of being able to leave the country
that would be a really big deal it would
be unprecedented for a former president
to be unable to leave the country but is
that actually what happened was it a
mix-up did trump lie we're still trying
to figure it out it started with donald
trump posting on truth social quote wow
in the raid by the fbi of mar-a-lago
they stole my three passports one
expired along with everything else this
is an assault on a political opponent at
a level never seen before in our country
third world
now is it actually what happened we
don't really know because there was a
statement late last night that the fbi
is not in possession of the passports
now is not in possession is a statement
about the right then it's not a
statement about we never had them it
just means we don't have them at this
exact point in time
we later
uh found out about an email
that was sent from
someone uh in law enforcement um
presumably to people on trump's side
saying we have learned that the filter
agents seized three passports belonging
to president trump two expired and one
being his active diplomatic passport we
are returning them and they will be
ready for pickup at 2 p.m today i'm
traveling but you can coordinate further
with whoever uh redacted copied above
now if that was indeed 2pm it would make
the statement from the fbi last night
accurate that they were not in
possession of the passports
but they had them at cert at a certain
point uh we later uh i guess this
morning got another report from nbc news
trump's passports returned after
mar-a-lago search per doj official in a
message on his social media platform
trump said the fbi agents who searched
his home last week quote stole three
passports including one that he said was
expired the fbi acknowledged it had had
the passports the same day trump said on
his social media platform that they took
them on august 8th
um a justice department official said
trump's passports have been returned so
we we really don't know exactly
what happened here why was trump looking
for his passports how did he know that
they were in the boxes that he claimed
were planted by the fbi
i've never gone looking for my passport
when i wasn't planning to leave the
country as a sort of curiosity
it's all very strange but it does not
appear that the overall intention of the
fbi
was to semi-permanently prevent donald
trump from leaving the country that
would be a major major thing
why did they take the passports and give
them back was it an accident were the
passports in these particular boxes
we don't know but it's all very very
strange
i do what i can
when it comes to climate change because
this is one of the most important issues
of our time if we don't have a planet
it's hard to do much about women's
rights or campaign finance or whatever
and i do whatever i can at the
individual level bearing in mind that
corporations also have to change a lot
to reduce my climate footprint this
includes being aware of how far is my
food coming from or how much trash am i
generating these types of things and
this is why our sponsor rent is so
important ren is a chartered public
benefit company and they unlock the
collective action of individuals against
climate change and ren is a very simple
and effective way to make a difference
on climate rent is a website where you
calculate your carbon footprint
personally you answer a few questions
about your lifestyle
wren will then tell you what your carbon
footprint is and let you offset it
by funding a diverse mix of carbon
reduction projects like tree planting
mineral weathering rainforest protection
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint you'll get monthly updates
from the projects you support and you'll
get to see where is your money going
you'll see photos you'll get details it
will take a lot to end the climate
crisis but you can start offsetting your
carbon footprint today and wren will
cover the first month of your
subscription for free when you sign up
at ren dot co slash david the link is
down below